Ще в вересні 2019-го, відразу після призначення,
уряду Олексія Гончарука, згідно з опитуваннями,
довіряли майже дві третини українців.
А вже наприкінці лютого 2020 понад дві третини громадян
Гончаруку і його кабміну НЕ довіряють. У чому ж причина?
І які саме дії уряду зазнали найбільшої критики усього за півроку роботи?
Обіцяного й довгоочікуваного економічного дива
в Україні у 2019 не сталося: рік закінчився
падінням промвиробництва. Темпи згортання -
близько 7,5% - стали найвищими від часів
економічної кризи 2014-15-го років. Серед причин,
пояснюють експерти, не лише внутрішні, як-от
зміцнення курсу гривні, а й зовнішні:
так, зокрема, зміна кон'юнктури на світовому ринку
в результаті торгових війн між США і Китаєм
позначилася на конкурентоспроможності
українських металургів. Від кризи у 2019-му Україну
врятував добрий урожай і високі прибутки аграріїв,
а ще - прихід іноземного спекулятивного капіталу
завдяки високим ставкам доходності українських
боргових паперів - облігацій внутрішньої державної позики.
"План порятунку" економіки зрештою звівся
до перегляду бюджету та іміджевих кроків:
міністр економіки оголосив про створення
спеціального антикризового штабу.
У зону відповідальності уряду втрутився президент,
пообіцявши інвесторам податкові канікули
та персональних радників - "інвестиційних нянь".
Втім, ці кроки результатів поки не дали й,
на думку експертів, самі по собі навряд чи
допоможуть поліпшити ситуацію.
Сигналом для інвесторів і додатковим ресурсом
для економіки могли би стати гроші, отримані
в рамках співпраці з МВФ. Попередня програма
завершилась у січні 2020 року, а нову -
на 5 із половиною мільярдів доларів
упродовж трьох років - поки не затвердила
рада директорів фонду. Перемови розпочав
ще уряд Володимира Гройсмана, але так і не завершив.
Серед вимог, які фонд висунув уже урядові
Олексія Гончарука, - ухвалення закону про продаж землі,
завершення реформи податкової та митної служб,
а також ухвалення закону, який не допустить
повернення націоналізованого ПриватБанку колишнім власникам.
А ще - прозора приватизація держпідприємств.
Самотужки реалізувати всі ці вимоги Кабміну
не під силу. Чимала частка відповідальності лежить
на Верховній Раді, яка тільки закон про зняття земельного мораторію
розглядає кілька тижнів поспіль.
Прозоре ціноутворення й дешевший газ
українцям обіцяв уряд і Гончарук особисто.
Зрештою реформа газового ринку обернулася скандалом.
Появу двох платіжок - за доставку та, власне, саме
блакитне паливо, - кабміну довелося пояснювати постфактум,
як і виправдовуватися, чому попри рекордно теплу зиму
суми в платіжках за січень зросли порівняно із грудневими.
Таким чином удавана "перемога" кабміну -
укладення угоди з Росією про транспортування газу українською ГТС -
для українців здобутком не стала. У соцмережах
вони обурювалися, навіщо взагалі цей договір, якщо
Україна отримує газ із Європи,
чому за транспортування доводиться платити навіть тим,
хто газ не отримує, і яким чином зміниться якість послуг.
У Кабміні у відповідь пообіцяли тільки, що
суми в платіжках за лютий будуть меншими.
Уряд Гончарука став мішенню численних інформаційних атак.
У середині січня в мережу злили аудіозаписи
начебто наради прем'єра з міністрами і керівництвом НБУ
щодо стану української економіки. На них голос,
схожий на голос Гончарука, стверджував,
що у Зеленського "дуже примітивне розуміння економіки",
а "сам я (тобто Гончарук) - теж профан в економіці".
Попри очікування, відставки Гончарука
тоді не відбулось. Хоча згаданий "злив" збігся в часі
з іншим урядовим скандалом щодо розмірів
премій і зарплат міністрів та інших урядовців.
Після втручання президента Гончарук оголосив, що
віднині зарплати міністрів максимально сягатимуть
3-5 середніх зарплат по країні, а найвища премія
не перевищуватиме посадового окладу.
Найочевиднішим провал урядових комунікацій
став під час так званого "коронавірусного скандалу".
Спочатку Кабмін не міг визначитися
з датою евакуації українських громадян із Китаю,
а потім - із місцем розташування їх на обсервацію.
Зрештою одразу в кількох областях,
куди планували доправити евакуйованих,
спалахнули протести. Публічну незгоду
висловлювали не лише ті, хто блокував дороги
до санаторіїв, а й місцеві депутати й інші політики.
Апогеєм скандалу стали сутички поліції
та учасників акції у Нових Санжарах.
Перш ніж міністри встигли поспілкуватися
з місцевим населенням і пояснити іншим громадянам України,
що відбувається, світ облетіли кадри сутичок:
каміння в вікна автобуса з евакуйованими,
озброєні правоохоронці й обличчя "народного гніву".
Найкраще, що змогли вигадати в Кабміні, -
помістити на "карантин" разом із евакуйованими
міністерку охорони здоров'я.
Експерти не виключають, що безпорадність
перед "коронавірусним скандалом" може бути
останньою краплею у невдоволенні урядом Олексія Гончарука.